[موسيقى]
هناك بعض الفوائد التي كتنتج عن الصيام
منها اثناء الصيام يحدث تحسن ملحوظ في
وظائف المعده والمريء مما يؤدي الى عدم
ارتجاع الحامض الى الصدر مما ياتي يؤدي
الى تحسن كبير في وظائف الرئه وخصوصا
لمريض حساسيه الصدر ايضا اثناء الصيام
هناك تجنب كبير لبعض المواد الدهنيه اثناء
الصيام مما يؤدي الى تحسن في وظائف القلب
والاوعيه الدمويه مما يؤدي الى تحسن
الدوره الدمويه داخل الرئه فيؤدي الى
تبادل
الاكسجين مع ثاني اكسيد الكربون بصفه سلسه
مما يؤدي الى تحسن في وظائف الرب وحساسيه
الصدر ايضا
[موسيقى]
هناك بعض الاضرار التي يجب على المريض
تجنبها او التعامل معها من الصيام وهي
اثناء الصيام يحصل جفاف شديد اثناء النهار
مما يؤدي الى لزوج كبيره بالسوائل
والافرازات داخل الجهاز التنفسي
لتجنب هذا الموضوع يجب على المريض تناول
كميات وسوائل كبيره من الماء والعصائر
الطبيعيه في الفتره ما بين الافطار
والسحور من لا تقل عن ثلاثه لتر من
السوائل ايضا يجب على المريض اثناء
الافطار تناول وجبه الافطار بكميات قليله
على فترات متقاربه حتى لا يتم ملء المعده
بكميه كبيره من الطعام مره واحده تؤدي الى
تدهور في وظائف المعده وارتجاع الحامض الى
الصدر مما يؤدي الى تهيج شديد في حساسيه
الصدر ونوصي ايضا بعض المرضى الذين يعانون
من انواع الحساسيه لانواع معينه من الطعام
كنوع المكسرات كنوع الاسماك ايضا في بعض
انواع
التشوكليت تجنب هذه الاطعمه بصفه قاطعه
لان هذا قد يؤدي الى تهيج في حساسيه الصدر
ويؤدي الى ادخال المريض في ازمه ربويه
حاده
[موسيقى]